hey guys dr. Burke here in this video I
want to talk about cancer and what I
would eat if I had cancer okay but first
let me just cover some facts number one
cancer depends on glycolysis what does
that mean that means that a cancer
depends on the metabolism of sugar
it runs on sugar metabolism okay
the uptake of glucose is 10 to 12 times
more for cancer than it is for normal
cells so again
cancer will suck up the glucose more
than normal cells that's interesting
glucose will increase tumor growth okay
because it's probably because it it
triggers insulin which is a anabolic it
builds things up it makes things get
bigger high blood sugar levels will
increase the risk of breast cancer
interesting PET scans which are
basically called positron emission
tomography is they inject you with
radioactive glucose and the cancer cells
like have a frenzy and they eat up all
this glucose and you can find out where
they are okay because of this fact so
based on this what do you think you're
gonna avoid if you have cancer what is
the number one thing can you take a wild
guess it's sugar of course so basically
I am already eating as if I have cancer
and I'll cover that in a second but I
just wanted to mention another pointer
there's an organization called the
American Cancer Society okay they're
kind of like the opinion leaders of what
to do when you have cancer what you want
to do is you want to read their site
study what they recommend and do the
exact opposite let me tell you why this
is what they tell you to do stay out of
the Sun well how are you gonna get your
vitamin D vitamin D is so important in
building up your immune system and no
vitamin the Sun is not a problem okay
this is another thing they said men
should consume no more than two drinks a
day alcoholic drinks per day and women
shouldn't drink more than one
so they're gonna allow you to do two
drinks or even one every single day if
you have cancer does that make sense
no you want to drink zero alcohol if you
have cancer they say that no evidence
that GMO foods are harmful well they
have to say that politically because
they're probably funded by Monsanto but
we know that GMO is harmful and it does
cause cancer they recommend two and a
half cups of vegetables per day two and
a half cups that's not gonna do anything
you need like seven to ten cups they
tell you to reduce your sugar well
that's good but we need to eliminate
this sugar because of this okay we want
to starve off that cancer at least slow
it down they also said that there's no
evidence that organic food is healthier
than commercial Hood well what about all
the pesticides insecticides herbicides
fungicides if you look at any toxicology
book you'll see that that's stuff
triggers cancer interesting so what do
we need to do we need to avoid all all
sugars and that includes the refined
breads and pastas and syrups we need to
avoid that why because it the cancer
lives on that stuff number two
cruciferous vegetables now of course all
my videos on versiv pretty much telling
you to do this
cruciferous vegetables kale brussel
sprouts broccoli cabbage all those foods
are highly effective in improving the
immune system and supporting the immune
system and they're very anti-cancer okay
the World Health Organization I mean has
this book I should do a video on it it
shows you all the research that it's
done in cancer it's amazing but there's
not a lot of profit in it now garlic out
of all the foods that you can eat garlic
is the the top food for anti-cancer
properties so that's something that you
should also start consuming lots of
vitamin D from the Sun yeah absolutely
and grass-fed animal products you don't
want to do commercial because primarily
the feeds
they feed these animals GMO grains
specifically soy so you want to not
consume animals that consume that
because I believe that effects
cancer puts you at risk and I think the
last thing I would do which doesn't have
nothing to do with eating and I would
I'm gonna do a whole video on this and
it's you're gonna have to figure out how
you're gonna drop your stress way down
because I do know that stress can
activate cancer if you talk to people
that get cancer a lot of times it
happens after a stress event it it just
kicks in the whole cascade our bodies
are constantly battling cancer cells
there's a normal thing in our body
called apoptosis which is the normal
program cell death and we're constantly
killing between 30 and 50 billion cells
every single day as a normal thing they
keep everything in check so it doesn't
get out of control and it's the out of
control nature of that system that
happens with cancer but putting these
things in will definitely act as a
preventative measure and slow it down
and help you control it so anyway put
your comments below tell me what you
think hey guys thank you so much for
watching please click the subscribe
button and I will see you in the next
video